this November I'm hitting the road for
an 18 City live tour and I'm bringing
some very funny comedians with me
really excited about this it's car yeah
it's called as you can see it's called
it's called Conan and Friends and
evening of stand-up and investment tips
okay I do need to mention there will be
no investment tips given that was a
printing error and trust me you don't
want my investment tips because I've
made some doozies in my day sure yeah I
went on all in on Enron but anyway look
it up it's a funny reference and that's
the kind of those are the kind of gems
you're gonna get no it's gonna be a lot
of fun I'm kidding I'm kidding
tickets go on sale this Friday at 10:00
a.m. for more information and to see if
we're coming to your city because we're
going to a lot of cities go to team
koco.com slash tour and this entire
thing is sponsored by our good friends
at Sam Adams who are making it possible
I'm really excited to get on the road
and hear all of your complaints about my
show in person this is your chance this
is your chance so please I will see you
there thank you
you